[Musique]
émilie nicolas sébastien bovet christian
dufour bonsoir bonsoir merci particulier
à sébastien vous vous trouvez que vous
étiez passé en nombre d' aujourd'hui
sébastien avec vos deux émissions vous
intervention téléjournal à 24,60 donc
c'était avant d'ajouter un excellent
david j'espère qu'on salue il ya eu 1 ça
arrive une mauvaise cru nication je vous
remercie sébastien plaisir d'être là
les taxes de monsieur duhaime va
commencer en fin de semaine vendredi ou
samedi quand ça a commencé j'étais chez
les conservateurs en tout cas ça a
commencé en fin de semaine et là ça a
pris quelques jours avant qu'on est
l'explication je vais vous faire écouter
ceux qui n'étaient pas avec nous
l'explication de monsieur duhaime et la
réaction de deux autres chefs
le locataire est aussi un ami c'est un
père de quatre enfants comme cohn bendit
mondiaux de la mesure à payer ses
factures à fin du mois malheureusement
on à l'entente qu'on avait c'était pas
compliqué parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
capables de payer un loyer comment on
voulait le faire au départ donc là il
dit ça a été de transférer ceux pour qui
payait jusqu'ici qu'entretiennent la
maison qui paye les les comptes courants
incluant les taxes incluant diderot
incluant une corde incluant le ton de
base on a peinturé maison de sept rôles
et les trucs de base et malheureusement
il n'ya pas y attarder puis c'est pour
ça que j'ai dû rembourser a posteriori
de l'ensemble des factures
quand on aspire à gouverner le québec on
doit respecter les règles en place
payer ses taxes et impôts c'est pas mal
la base on parle de la base alors
j'invite à tous les chefs de partis à
payer leurs taxes et leurs impôts et pas
essayé de se justifier pourquoi ils
l'ont pas fait
il ya les taxes municipales j'ai bien
compris l'hydro il y aller les taxes
scolaires
je me suis fait des amis puis j'aime ça
les a aidés là mais là je trouve ça
commence à faire beaucoup le
gentil avec mes amis comprenez-moi bien
mais je trouve que là il commence à
avoir beaucoup de choses
en tout cas il ya trois jours de
campagne au monsieur duhaime n'a parlé à
peu près que de ça a dû encore
publiquement il a voulu parler d'autre
chose mais c'est ce qu'on retient ml
qu'est ce que vous en dites
mais que ce soit que si c'était la seule
affaire qui s'était passé dans
l'histoire fiscale
mary jane passe quelque chose sur qui
effectivement je pense que dans la khl
il convient d'entendre de gabriel
nadeau-dubois il faisait allusion à un
historique ont fait de problèmes avec
albi nbi de problème pas de report du
paiement des droits des choses qu'on
savait déjà parce qu'il est des fois il
on ne parlait ni même radio
personnelle et publique donc c'est comme
si ça fait longtemps au fait qu éric
duhaime a des histoires un peu croche
par rapport à des comptes impayés puis
c'est pertinent dans la mesure où c'est
un homme qui fait campagne
énormément
changé
donc dans le l'individu moyen en rapport
avec le gouvernement donc dans cette
mesure là c'est sûr que lorsque ça fait
partie des thèmes principaux d'une
campagne la manière dont dans le même
genre nécessairement je pense que c'est
sébastien oui il espérait devenir
premier ministre du québec la question
sous jacente c'est si tu veux gérer 100
milliards de budget du gouvernement du
québec faut que ce soit aussi capable
faut que tu sois capable de gérer des
propres finances personnelles heures
c'est pas tant un événement mais c'est
l'accumulation la répétition des
événements qui fait en sorte qu' on peut
se poser des questions sur la façon dont
monsieur duhaime gère ses affaires en
même temps je suis à peu près convaincu
que ça va pas dissuadé la base militante
ferme de éric duhaime peut-être même que
ça va d'une certaine façon les mobiliser
encore plus parce qu'il est atteint il
se sent attaqué par les médias il aurait
dû monsieur duhaime plutôt essayer de
désamorcer la la grenade tout ce qui
traîne se salit on y sert dans la vie de
tous les jours mais c'est exactement la
même chose en politique il aurait dû
réagir plus tôt nous donner
l'explication à vous maintenant de
croire ou non cette explication ouais
christian s'attarder un peu
ouais j'suis d'accord que ça pourrait ne
pas démotiver sa base militante mais ça
peut lui enlever en fait les québécois
qui étaient tentés de magazines et puis
de voter pour éric duhaime parce que là
c'est la deuxième bévue est une fête
c'est qu'elle est totalement aux anglo
québécois en ce qui a trait au projet de
loi 96 se sont reproduits beaucoup de
québécois nationalistes qui avait été
tenté par ailleurs de voter pour eric
dur et cette question l'ade et des taxes
et des comptes impayés c'est très
mauvais pour lui parce que lui même un
mec qui est technique du off road c'est
un principaux il se trouve c'est un
thème très bon c'est de dire qu'au
québec on est rodé responsabiliser ils
prêchent la liberté individuelle et la
responsable des citoyens alors payer ses
impôts on n'aime pas ça tu payer les
factures on n'aime pas ça mais c'est
assez élémentaires comme devoir donc
c'est mauvais pour lui parce qu'il ya
une contradiction entre un comportement
qui semble s'être ep ticket pour
criminels qui pas dramatique mais ça
contredit en fait ce dont il est
partante aussi enfin pourquoi ces
mauvaises c'est que ça rend très facile
de le ridiculiser
je vois les humoristes en fait s'en
donner à coeur joie au jeu que donc
c'est pas bon pour moi il ya deux
semaines quand il avait participé à
l'émission le copain ni en partie paquet
cela les des cinq chefs qui a été reçue
j'avais trouvé ce magistral je m'étais
dit s'ils continuent comme ça il va
faire des ravages mais le depuis ce
temps le une fête qui s'est collé
totalement jean-loup québécois j'ai
cette affaire-là ont offert des
négligences qui la lui lui même
vous êtes deux prises contre lui dans
votre esprit en tout cas pour pour aller
les convaincus qu'on était quand même
pour lui mais elle avait donc tu peux
être tentés de voter pour rituel c'est
cela qui peut perdre hockey en tout cas
dans une campagne quand on dit gagner ou
perdre une journée là ça fait quand même
depuis samedi matin qu'il perd trois
journées entre guillemets de suite le
temps ces cépages sait pas donc ça
s'étire comme ça comme didier sébastien
iwuy et si ça vous voulez encore un
intérêt vous voulez gagner chacune des
journées bas voulait gagner le plus de
journée pour cible et reed j'aime les a
pas gagnés c'est sûr que les curieux les
uns des six vont probablement voir ça
comme un mauvais pas d'un duel est
peut-être dû tourner bon que pensez vous
de cette longue d'une tradition leur nom
aux traditions c'est facile ici là ça
deux fois là que ça arrive à peu près
depuis 2018 qu'on demande
aux chefs de dévoiler leurs actifs
combien vous valez vous et votre famille
immédiate
on va voir le tableau on l'a vu un peu
plus tôt alors ils se prêtent au jeu
effectivement madame anglade avec son
conjoint qui ils valent 12,5 millions on
prend les maisons prend moins les dettes
puis on arrive à l'actif voilà messieurs
legault 7,8 millions monsieur duhaime à
deux passants monsieur duhaime les gens
vont dire ben alors les moyens de payer
ses factures mais bon je passe par st
pierre plamondon
410 mais les questions d'âge aussi me
suis simplement dit on à polar je me
suis le gonflement et gabriel
nadeau-dubois 104 milles de là est ce
que c'est une bonne tradition ce que
c'est un exercice de transparence dans
une démocratie qui est souhaitable c'est
importé des états unis faut vous
comprends je commence avec vous
christian puis je vous entends les trois
christian moi ça me met très mal à
l'aise je trouve que tu voyeurisme là
dedans je t'ai vraiment contre son
départ parce que la vie privée c'est
important je te dis c'est devenu une
coutume et c'est très dur maintenant
pour les chefs politiques de poursuivre
la coutume ils vont jouer sur le fait
qu'ils vont donner plus ou moins
d'informations c'est là dessus qu'ils
jouent mais moi je le répète au départ
ou moi je te raconte ça ça me savais des
états unis et ce qui vient des saisines
et parfois c'est pas tellement bon on le
sait où et sébastien ça s'est inscrit on
lave au municipal denis coderre avait
refusé de lire de rendre publics
certains contre up sell l'a suivi
pendant une semaine parce que si vous le
rendrai pas public vous donnez
l'impression où ça peut être interprété
comme si vous avez quelque chose à
cacher alors celle là ils sont dans
l'engrenage et je présume pour les
autres campagnes chaque chef fera la
même chose moi je suis déchiré entre la
curiosité parce qu'on est fait de voir
combien valent chacun des chefs ya une
certaine curiosité voire du voyeurisme
pour reprendre l'expression utilisée par
christian
mais en même temps on veut en plus
souvent comment ils gèrent ils veulent
gérer le québec comment gère-t-il leurs
propres finances à qui s'adresse-t-il
aussi lorsqu'il est question de la
classe moyenne par exemple quels types
de revenus ils font eux mêmes et ce
qu'ils peuvent s'identifier cette classe
moyenne ou pas ça peut répondre à
certaines de ces questions mais je suis
embêté ballon je vous dirais sur la
pertinence de cette démarche là dans le
cadre d'une campagne un taux intéressant
ml
mais je pense que la raison pour
laquelle c'est une tradition si forte
aux etats-unis c'est parce que étant
donné le rôle de l'argent du privé dé
financement des compagnies non système
dans le système américain c'est vraiment
important de comprendre où sont les
intérêts financiers des gens qui sont
dans la vie publique ici le rôle de
l'argent est moindre mais il y est quand
même là d'un cas par exemple de dénis
coderre lorsqu'on parlait des contrastes
d'une question de savoir de qui pour qui
le travail et qu'est ce que ça leur
regard
dans sa plate forme politique comme mr
donc c'était d'importance pub et quand
je regarde ce qui se passe en ce moment
avec la crise du logement moi ce que je
trouve particulièrement d'intérêt public
c'est d'avoir la quantité parle de gens
parmi les chefs qui sont des
propriétaires de deux immeubles
essentiellement qui ont des revenus
locatifs
quand il ya des gens qui défendent les
droits des locataires et conseils moi je
suis trop soit pertinent de savoir il ya
combien de personnes en fait à
l'assemblée nationale qui sont des
propriétaires personnels qui sont des
propriétaires d'immeubles à revenus et
combien de gens la somme et la salade
qui sont essentiels pour imprimantes de
la corpiq la même chose dans la com des
communes je trouve que donc un
revirement dans le contexte de la crise
du logement au delà du détail de tous
les chiffres la question de la propriété
peut devenir une question très
pertinente et toute affinité république
ok christian conclut
notre respect pour ce qu'il est mais il
est juste nous avoir agi ce moi ça me
met j'entendais mais des collègues ça
mais vraiment très profondément mal à
l'aise sauf si un dessin c'est leur vie
privée puis je trouve que moi je ne
demande pas aux politiciens en fait des
simples ça m'intéresse pas de savoir ce
qu'on fait avec leur agent jouets qu'ils
prennent de bonnes décisions de
politiques publiques et là on s'éloigne
de plus en plus de son nez de plus en
plus dans la morale dans la pureté à
l'américaine vous écart - est-ce que
vous êtes christian autrement dit c'est
moi qui ai une fraude à moins qu'il ya
des gestes illégaux
ok je te regarde en matière de logement
si on parle de politique qui servent à
augmenter
les sondages
lésions comparé par exemple aux
fédérales de hausser les taux d'intérêt
ou de construire plus de logements qui
fait en sorte qu'on baisse la propriété
bas
moyenne des propriétés pour qu'allah
plus jeunes générations puissent avoir
accès à la propriété lorsqu'on regarde
le portfolio des élus actuels à la
salle une pertinence dans le débat
au-delà du voyeurisme
au delà de la protection de la vie
privée donc je comprends qu'il ya des
choses que c'est effectivement il peut
avoir du voyeurisme et lorsqu'on parle
spécifiquement la question de la
propriété c'est tellement une question
d'intérêt public les élus ont tellement
la pâte directement dans prendre des
décisions qui peuvent avantager les
propriétaires ou les locataires je pense
que ça sonne à ce niveau là c'est pas
une question de moyens c'est vraiment
intéressant bon il est arrivé samedi
comme une balle
jamais on n'avait vu un bain jamais en
tout cas de mémoire d'homme on n'avait
pas vu un chef arrive est ainsi au score
il a battu rares peu monsieur pierre
poilievre des images qui arrivent à la
tête du parti conservateur du canada il
ouvre les bras il a des bons mots pour
ses adversaires monsieur charest il dit
merci pour ce que vous avez fait pour le
canada y remonter assez loin herman cain
95 il l'a pas féliciter pour ce qu'il a
fait dans la course
après des attaques très dures dans une
course a été très dure et la voici
qu'aujourd'hui on va écouter monsieur
rays et monsieur poilievre réponse est
un des députés québécois ne serait ce qu
il savait vous moi je me sens pas bien
là dedans c'est trop pour moi trop
d'attaqués trop une politique à
l'américaine trop de colère si je vais
résumer on écoute pourri
je suis arrivé à une conclusion
je ne me retrouve plus à l'intérieur de
ma propre formation politique avec elle
je me suis investi depuis maintenant
sept ans et j'ai avisé il ya quelques
minutes le président de la chambre des
communes pour l'informer qu'à partir de
maintenant je souhaitais continuer à
siéger mais à titre de député
indépendant
il a décidé de ne pas combattre
l'inflation de justin trudeau à nous
travaillons pour combattre les déficits
et les taxes inflationnistes qu'impose
justin trudeau
les citoyens de du comté de los reyes
sont d'accord ils ont voté pour moi dans
la course à la chefferie
sébastien je vous donne la parole
monsieur résiderait spa les citoyens
c'est les militants conservateurs qui
ont effectivement majoritairement et
voter pour monsieur poilievre dans la
circonscription mais un chef veut pas
voir sa civic quand même nom mais la
réaction de pierre poilievre est une
réaction vexé c'est à dire que il aurait
pu saluer la contribution dans l'airé
rsa aurait pu dire qui comprend pourquoi
ils quittent qu' il pouvait avoir des
désaccords idéologiques mais de dire
qu'il veut pas lutter contre l'inflation
probablement que c'est faux parce que
monsieur rees veut certainement lutter
contre les méfaits de l'inflation cela
étant dit ce cas les reyes qui en fait
une question de conviction de principe
aurait pas pu attendre un peu devoir de
juger l'arbre à ses fruits de voir
comment pierre poilievre chef du parti
conservateur se comportent pas ce que
pierre poilievre candidat à la direction
du parti c'est une chose est ce que
pierre poilievre chef du parti
conservateur va tenir le même discours
que pendant la campagne il a décidé de
prendre ses décisions tout de suite est
de ne pas attendre de voir comment
monsieur poilievre s'adapte à ces
nouvelles fonctions peut-être qu'il
aurait pu attendre un peu mais de toute
évidence il y avait une cassure
idéologique profonde qui faisaient que
mesurée elle se sentait plus à sa place
et sans jouer au puy scanner il y avait
une blessure aussi parce que les
partisans poilievre il entourage insu
poilievre a été très dur envers à l'airé
est ce qui à leurs yeux représentait la
vieille garde et jean charest dans le
cas qui nous occupe emilie qu'est ce que
j'avais pensé d'aujourd'hui
la réponse de pierre poilievre du tout
je dire quand un député qui quitte ton
cul c'est qui lui mais si le kid mon
caucus pas ce qui compte n'est pas bon
ni pour la lutte on lève pas ressenti ce
que pense que c'était contre la lutte à
l'inflation ça montre à quel point c'est
justement je pensais ce genre de
communication politique auquel alain rey
s est profondément allergique donc c'est
un peu la poésie là dedans dans le fait
que ça soit sur la réaction au départ
d'alain weill est ce qu'on a vu dans la
nomination aussi de son équipe
parlementaire 1 pierre paul yves gagné
avec tellement de beaux résultats qu'il
met paul pour tendre la main aux gens
qui seraient dû suivre n'est pas là pour
mettre de l'eau dans son vin dans sa
manière de de défendre ses idées avant
même d'être chef c'est une personne qui
était reconnue à la chambre des communes
pourrait être extrêmement partisane
il pouvait défendre tout et son
contraire si c'était la ligne du parti
et je pense qu'ils vont exiger à peu
près la même chose de ses députés que
quand il ya quelqu'un qui évoque avec
qui ça fait pas son affaire la personne
peut quitter et à et en 2000 la
popularité qu'il au sein du caucus du
mouvement la confirmation lui absolument
absolument du caucus et du mouvement
pour l'instant à l'intérieur du parti je
pense que ceux qui veulent unir on va
voir la photo d'ailleurs il a présenté
une belle photo devant les marches de sa
nouvelle équipe pierre paul hus ce
devient de nouveau lieu de temps pour le
québec est un douche il devient leader à
la chambre c'est intéressant donc
christian est sur le départ de ray est
semée et sur l'arrivée de poilievre là
je vous ai pas entendu
web un monsieur réel c'est un homme de
principe donc il a décidé de quitter en
fait de pas laisser la chambre chance au
coureur ou nouveau chef du parti
conservateur c'est clair que ça jette de
l'ombre en fait sur le triomphe de me
suivre police en fait depuis son succès
aussi envers la poche arrière des
francophones s'étaient très souligné que
beaucoup qui veut qu'on doté à quel
point pour une fois on entendait un chef
conservateur par le français qu on
comprenait facilement et puis la
performance de sa femme qui parlait très
bien français la québécoise aussi été
celui dont il s'agit dans le plus nombre
sur le succès de monsieur paul yves en
fin de semaine jeudi si monsieur et elle
c'était pour partir peut-être que c'est
mieux qu'ils partent tout de suite
plutôt qu'ils partent dans trois ou
quatre mois je si les pommes et en fait
semaine là vous me demandez ce que j'ai
trouvé c'est quand cette semaine me
serais tu pas que tout est changé mais
la politique fédérale fondamentalement
changé c'est qu'on a vu une force vitale
celle du coprah lièvre on peut avoir des
critiques qui remarque que j ai mis
nicolas tantôt est très juste veulent la
réaction de monsieur x liéval ayant ce
n'est pas le départ de monsieur
quand il disait qu en effet metz une
force vitale qui est arrivé il ya un
charisme une séduction c'est autre chose
que d'avoir la réaction immédiate de
justin trudeau aujourd'hui shoulders une
réaction de faiblesse il juste tout
chèque tout de suite ça sera plus pareil
il y entre en compétition il ya un noyau
nouveau combat on cesse là dessus ce
sera plus pareil la partie vient de
changer on a eu cette nette impression
de l'état à ottawa en fin de semaine
c'est très clair à vous trois sébastien
en particulier merci merci